this is a wasp nest
in the wild some of these nests are
built underground using clay or mud
but you might be most familiar with the
paper nests the ones built out of saliva
and pulp
typically found attached to buildings or
trees and these guys can get
big according to the guinness book of
world records the largest wasp nest was
12 feet long and 18 feet
all around now we're all accustomed to
avoiding these nests because obviously
wasps are scary but today we're going to
go inside one
because there are a lot of fascinating
factors that make these nests work for
wasps
and their babies so let's cut into one
pretty easy to cut through this the
hardest part was definitely here at the
top
where you can tell the cells are more
dense
and wider
if i can give you a scale for how big
this is i mean like look at it next to
my head
this is like a brick cell phone from the
90s the key to this type of nest
is the pedicel or the root it's the
foundation that the entire nest is built
off of
these are the cells wasps are like
butterflies
they're what's called hollow metabolis
insects meaning they go through a
metamorphosis before they become adults
and these cells are basically their
cribs the cells are open when they first
produced the queen will lay their egg in
there and then they'll get sealed off
they're shaped similar to a hollow
cylinder more like a regular lead school
pencil
and there's a reason why the walls of
the hexagon
hold the other cells also very compact
space so you can get a lot of these
cells in very very small space
while still having a very strong
structure they're also perfectly sized
to fit both the larva
and its roommates oftentimes there's
some food
laid in with the eggs so in hatches it
has the food in there already
the drones move from cell to cell in a
circular motion
making sure that each larvae has food
some wasp species tear up insects for
the babies
but other wasps take things further
mason wasps drop off
whole caterpillars for their children to
eat alive while tarantula hawk wasps
lay their eggs on tarantulas they sting
and paralyze as a birthday feast
other species lay their eggs inside
their prey and once the larva hatch
they have a meal waiting for them to
chew their way out of
once the larva is ready to metamorphose
it'll become a pupa inside the cell
still
and then it'll hatch as an adult
since the cells are both the crib and
the cocoon for these wasp babies
the nest must maintain a stable
temperature with high humidity
this means as much insulation as
possible for these types of nests
the domes are almost always made of
salivary secretions
plant material or paper or cardboard
so they take wood they chewed up
and they mix it with saliva to make a
glue
and then they lay it in thin layers
the denser the layers the stronger and
more sturdy the structure after building
the core structure
the queen wraps the entire nest in an
envelope these
thin sheets of macerated pulp this layer
basically protects the comb
or each layer of cells limiting the
entrance to one
tiny little hole scientists think this
helps to maintain the internal
temperature
and humidity of the structure and more
combs can be added on with more pedocels
sort of like expanding a mansion with
tiny little staircases that the wasps
can use to get from one area to another
so now i know the question on some of
your minds is
is there honey in a wasp-ness and the
answer is no
while both bees and wasps pollinate
flowers
bees actually farm nectar to turn it
into honey the food source for their
larvae
most wasps on the other hand are meat
eaters and prefer a diet of freshly
chewed insects
meaning you won't find honey in their
nests but you might find a lot of dead
bugs
so the next time you see one of these
nests and you're tempted to knock it
down
maybe back off those wasps put a lot of
effort into building this crib for their
babies
we don't want to take them off